[DOOR OPENING]
We pick up right where
we left the Turners
at the end of Season One.
Do you have him?
Who?
[HEAVY BREATHING]
The child is missing--
--and Dorothy believes that
the cult has taken their child.
Her-- this woman was in my house
today, and she took Jericho.
Part of what makes a
thriller is stakes.
And the timetable
is critical to that.
So in her mind, she has 48 hours
to find this baby, or else.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You need to establish roadblocks
on a 50 mile perimeter
around this city.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I shouldn't have to tell
you how to do your job.
Sean is halfheartedly
looking for the baby
because there is no baby
to look for in his mind.
So he's in an in-between
place of I'm not sure.
I think I lost my mind too.
Dorothy hasn't been
right since the accident.
She's not crazy.
No one is using that word.
The way I saw Dorothy
was very theatrical.
And the turmoil
that's going on in her
is being represented
by her mania
both in front of the camera,
but also in real life.
Don't just stand there!
Do something!
I try to show it, even in the
clothing and the big patterns
that she's wearing.
There's a sense of the
things that are going wrong.
This not a person at peace.
This is not a person
that's balanced.
[GASP]